playstation is defined by its exclusives
and that's especially true over its most
recent generations some of which are an
absolute necessity to play if you have a
ps4 or ps5 console so we put together a
list of 15 exclusives that should
absolutely
not be missed
sure the dark souls series is what
developer from software is most widely
known for but for anyone who's had a
good dose of bloodborne in their
bloodstream knows that that game is
possibly the studio's strongest title
it's like dark souls but gothic
terrifying vicious and
way more blood soaked no doubt that it's
just as difficult as the souls series
riddled with a haunting story
cryptically interlaced through its world
but bloodborne just hits different it's
way faster and way spookier it also has
this hot mama
it's a part of the ps plus collection so
if you haven't played it yet well then
maybe it's time that you learn to fear
the old blood
death stranding certainly has a unique
approach to open world game design one
that's spent walking around keeping your
balance climbing uneven terrain and
delivering packages it's hard to
understand its appeal at first glance
but at its roots it's a game about
connecting an america that's become
disbanded fractured and forced into
hiding due to a grave and commanding
threat it's a little too on the nose in
our post 2020 world but that makes it
all the more poignant and worth playing
today also you best believe it's as
off-kilter as you'd expect coming from
the mind of kojima the director's cut of
the game is coming out on september 24th
with updated visuals and new content
besides it also has norman ritas taking
care of a baby and drinking monster
energy drinks so yeah
okay yeah we already mentioned
bloodborne but we can't possibly ignore
the game that started it all demon souls
it's the game that put from software on
the map as the studio who would become
known for brutally challenging action
rpgs when it originally came out it was
more of a cult hit in comparison to the
later games in the series so it only
made sense to bring it back a decade
later as a launch game for the ps5 few
games showed off what the next
generation felt like as well as the
demon souls remake its textures lighting
load times and the use of the dual sets
are all remarkable remake studio blue
point games didn't change what made the
original masterpiece but instead
smoothed out the edges and presented the
modern classic as it should be seen
today
there has been a few game creation tools
released for consoles but none of them
have reached the heights of dreams
though dreams has a short campaign
created with in-game tools mind you and
it's really good the true star of the
show is the massive creation suite that
allows you to build pretty much whatever
you can think of from the ground up like
all tools it's kind of a learning curve
of course but the well of user made
creations is simply staggering and you
could easily spend hours upon hours
playing or watching other creators work
[Music]
after being announced only to slip back
into the shadows followed with multiple
delays and a complete revamping to its
design it's a surprise the final fantasy
remake even came out not to mention the
miraculous recapturing of the original's
essence but final fantasy remake does
more than just hone in on the magic of
the first but create something entirely
distinct that sets it as its own
marvelous adventure while it
controversially moved to real-time
combat the result paid off thanks to a
considered system that balanced strategy
over mindless hacking and slashing it
reimagined midgard in staggering detail
and emphasized its characters with more
depth than the original allowed the
result is a journey worth taking
regardless of whether you cared about
the first or not
ghost of sushima is the definitive
samurai game it's stitched together with
high noon drama scenic vistas stoic
heroes and
blood spray through and through it's a
love letter to classic samurai cinema
playing constant homage to the style of
films made legendary by director akira
kurosawa it has a beautiful open world
to explore or meditate with a spanning
combat system and some nice buns if you
haven't played this one give it a shot
it was recently released with a
director's cut with new content and
while you're at it you might as well go
give yo jimbo a watch you won't regret
it
[Music]
it's not often that a reboot of a
beloved franchise becomes the best game
in the series however sony santa
monica's god of war did well just that
it did more than just trade greek
mythology for norse it gives its leading
man some much needed depth and delivers
a story focused experience god of war
gives a new side to kratos one that's
more contemplative albeit still flawed
but more introspective especially with
the dynamic of his son atreus god of war
hands down has some of the best
cinematic action scenes ever made and is
layered with a thoughtful combat system
if you have a playstation 5 it has a
free upgrade that features 4k resolution
and 60 frames per second and is also a
part of the ps plus collection
[Music]
horizon zero dawn is one of the best
first party open world games for
playstation developer gorilla games
crafted a unique post-apocalyptic world
that feels both primitive and futuristic
and that's thanks to its robot dinosaurs
all of which is boasted thanks to a
great story with excellent combat that
involves studying a machine to figure
out the best approach to taking it down
the sequel horizon forbidden west is set
to release in february of 2022 for ps5
and ps4
the last of us was by many considered
the ps3's best game it was so damn good
and ended in such a way that the very
idea of a sequel was just controversial
it just didn't need one or so we thought
until the last of us part two came along
the whole thing is a meditation on
revenge and takes the time to see its
story of anguish and violence through
many different lenses the result is
something that is at times hard to
stomach and even uncomfortable and well
it's a topic that shouldn't be easy to
stomach in the first place it's combat
is a well-balanced ballet of action
violence and stealth which is
intricately packaged with a brilliantly
realistic world in heartbreaking
performances it's a display of naughty
dog's unflinching confidence and it
pushes the medium of games and
interactive storytelling in bold new
directions
[Music]
marvel's spider-man is easily one of the
best superhero games ever made swinging
through manhattan streets scoping out
its skylines from its highest points and
beating up baddies as spider-man has
never felt more spider-man like it's
also a great spidey story and an
incredibly well-written peter parker
it's follow-up spider-man miles morales
though a shorter adventure still
impresses thanks to the characterization
of miles morales the ps5 ultimate
edition includes marvel spider-man all
three expansions and the miles morales
campaign
bet you never saw this one coming
persona 5 royal is an expanded version
of one of the best jrpgs on ps4 but it's
more than a simple re-release with added
content it's got a whole bunch of new
stuff including a superb new palace
however most impressively is how it's
reworked its original content developer
atlas made sweeping changes to the
original story that helps it tie
together in a much more impactful and
meaningful way and regardless of whether
you're familiar with the persona
franchise or not this is a fresh start
so no context is needed to just jump in
and start stealing hearts the original
is available via ps plus collection but
we'd recommend opting for persona 5
royal if you can
[Music]
ratchet and clank rift apart is a
spectacle of the ps5's power its effects
environments low times are all turned up
to 11 including the dual sense haptic
feedback and adaptive triggers it's also
the introduction of rivet with a
storyline that interweaves alongside
ratchet giving two distinct gameplay
experiences including the new mechanic
of instantaneously transporting to holy
new environments and it's a whole bunch
of fun
[Music]
returnal takes the roguelike genre and
launches it into the aaa stratosphere
and beyond with the exception of the
game hades returnal is one of the few
games to take the roguelike formula and
infuse an engaging and thought-provoking
story throughout it it's also arguably
one of the most difficult games on this
list it uses the formula to deliver a
punishing experience that requires trial
and error to make progress with an
emphasis on dodging and nimble gun
gunplay it's one of the best ps5
exclusives but just be wary if you're
not a roguelike fan it may be hard to
get into
shadow of the colossus was one of the
best ps2 games in blue point games the
same studio behind the demon souls
remake brought it back in style with the
2018 remake just as it was 15 years ago
shadow the colossus is a towering feat
in storytelling and game design taking a
formula like zelda's dungeons and making
them physically walking towering colossi
that wander the world determining how to
topple the colossi is a part of the
mystery and requires more than just
platforming but puzzle solving and a bit
of ingenuity it's also just stunning to
look at and tells one gut punch of a
story
nathan drake swan's song brought naughty
dog's charming action adventure to a
fitting conclusion at least when it
comes to drake's arc uncharted 4 a
thief's end has more spacious set pieces
than early entries allowing for a more
free-form approach to exploration and
combat it feels less scripted than
drake's other adventures which in turn
provides a greater sense of discovery in
the adventure it's large in scope and it
balances its moving parts exceedingly
well to give a proper goodbye to one of
sony's most iconic characters you do
know that you're not actually nathan
drake you shut your mouth
you shut it it's a character i will cut
you i will open you up and bleed you out
and that wraps it up if you're a ps4 or
ps5 owner and haven't given any of these
a shot well consider taking the time to
squeeze it up on your backlog list
anyways thanks for watching and don't
forget to give us a thumbs if you liked
it and a sub for more gaming content
[Music]